we're still doing that speed but we're
gonna go down to a smaller kind of units
instead of bits per second I want to
introduce this idea of so board rate so
I'm starting going back in five years
boards a very old-fashioned word but
it's very useful to us right okay now
tell me who remembers baud rate yes okay
good
so that's quickly review this okay
because we looked at this other trans
minion receiving whoa I'm logging off
and shutting down okay so boy let's see
how much you can remember what is a
board board singular it's a noun what's
they refer to sorry say again three
minutes I'm just gonna get out somewhere
technology I'm gonna have to move the
camera though board rate what's a board
one board okay um why would you turn
this around give up here it probably
would not be fast enough for me okay oh
boy it was a single event do you
remember that signal events and we said
there were three different ways to
distinguish between these okay three
different kinds of ways to have
different signal of events and we said
they correspond to some things that you
are a little familiar with remember what
they were about well what were it's for
each one okay and if they were familiar
with these because of radio right so the
a stands for amplitude that means how
strong the signal is okay the F stands
for frequency which is how often the
signal comes okay and this last one was
a we might remember was phase right so
it was about the time and how you sync
signals to each other okay and remember
the M in all cases stands for modulation
good
okay now what does this all have to do
with all of these bits and that kind of
thing per second okay how two broad
relate two bits per second what depends
on how many different kind of variations
you've got right so for instance suppose
you have a transmitting device or a
receiving device that can handle four
different kinds of air puts you okay
one two three and four okay in terms of
the volume of the signal okay how many
bits per second could you send if you
have this number of different variations
okay and you had um one board board per
second four different variations how
many beats could you send think
carefully
and remember bits I'm not about this is
base 10 right what base are bits in
their base to write so the digits would
be say for instance zero there's my
first bit okay the next one would be one
then the next one could be one zero and
the one after that would be one one so
how many bits per second could I send if
I got four different variations
I can send chivitz right these are the
two bits I can send okay
so really a better way to write this is
this is two squared okay with four
different variations
I can send welcome back I can send 2
squared different kinds of signals okay
now let's keep on going
what if I have eight different
frequencies and another four different
phases okay
how many bits per second could I get
what is it
what's this power on this is to the
power of three and this is to the power
of 2 again right so for every one of
these two bits I've got three more kinds
of variations on it
right does that make sense to three let
this one
remember your index laws it is not a
maths classroom but when you multiply
these together you add their indices
right two five seven okay so the thing
you want to pay attention to is the
index right so I'm trying to connect
what you let last year about these
different ways to send signals with this
speed measurement of its percent okay